our work is finished Lucayan  Lord rain it falls upon you to architect  a new history then together let us begin  cease Liu Kang  before you doom us all say soon  [Music]  in defeating chronica you destroyed her  crime without it you can't restart  history  to the past to steal the crown from my  island before the hour glass shatters  why are we listening to the snake  because I am a snake who's toiled beside  chronica learning her secrets I know  them  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  we need help but whose help  [Music]  welcome back your highness what have you  done  [Music]  mustache Sora  before you betray us I find your lack of  faith amusing  [Music]  she can hate us again  I was her protector for life  [Music]  Shane sooner has become far too  dangerous and I doubt his new allies  realize quite how dangerous he is no one  can predict what happens next  not even me jintan need backup now  you are under arrest  dirtbag  [Music]  [Applause]